it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
all right we're good to go it's an old
school fighter kid couple things to get
out of the way that's a lot of color
it's our third one independent yup a lot
of color brennan hasn't had a thing to
eat doesn't stop him doing a little
nicotine uh some whiskey and some coffee
shots of coffee yep we got we got eight
shots of caffeine in his body probably
some kratom who knows who knows maybe
some testosterone we definitely have no
sir all right take it easy i'm just
saying no food
nicotine
booze whiskey and then some caffeine
it's going to be good but you know what
um and stress don't add some stress
because you got to run a business but
you got the important thing is you are
you and mark are screaming out of the
closet with matching colors you're
matching i didn't realize he had the
matching shirt and i love it i'm caught
i'm caught between a pink parade right
now and i appreciate that so then you
got a little light blue on dude i got
life and you got your sandals i got some
stuff to talk about i i got the gay
meter is at a nine and i appreciate it
how about you know a fan gave me this
hat usually when people give you gifts
whatever you know it's yeah it's cool
stuff or they made it or whether it's
art or whatever yep and then this lady
hand me a bag from mitchell ness
mitchell ness makes like all the vintage
like cool sports memorabilia i'm like
yeah okay i didn't look at it
thank you then i go in the back and i
was like well there's probably a towel
open i'm like oh that is
liddy that's litty yeah i'll take it i
throw back sixers out in philly and this
is my boy suplex and i like the shoes
now i wanted to i want to do a little
quiz i got you know i live in my toe
holds now i got i i just got they made
me a new pair yeah maybe a new pair now
that right there that strap you have one
guess each
as to what
animal
that's stressful this is easy this is
easy hold on baby rhino baby rhino you
killed a baby they skinned a baby rhino
alive do not buy these sand i like i
baby rhinos i like your attitude what
would you say this is uh if i i don't
know much about let me see it be let me
give a good look let me feel it feel
that
buffalo buffalo i like buffalo go ahead
chin what what say you and you can touch
it dude this is some sort of is it some
sort of monitor lizard
i like that these are and by the way
herman oak that's that's the dragon
edition take a look at that [ __ ] yeah
those dragons on your sandals hey hey my
favorite hey are you a bad guy for my
90s kung fu movie don't make fun of my
why are there some dragons on your sand
don't make fun of the uh touhou because
they're awesome no they are comfy but
don't have dragons all right i love this
it's one of our staples yeah i know but
right
no don't make fun no they are
dude you they've really gotten dope yeah
now here's now here's my problem hey
we're friends right yeah we're friends
right yeah now did i not give you a
bottle of tiger thick yes i did right
yeah um do i not give you things
whenever i can yeah yeah i'll give you
the shirt off my back yeah
i don't have these i'm going to get you
no hold on no these are our new model
right so now what happened was when we
you went back to the drawing board and
we were ready to see the drawing the
best sandals in the world now now best
santa see that's how it works
hey do i look like jesus christ you know
why i go because these sandals are from
back then that's right so when you said
say less you had what's called the firm
edition and i said these are a little
too hard so now we got the orthopedic
vibram and then we got the hermann oak
leather which the more you wear the
better on your feet right hey right now
now now what would we still do in our
our quiz here oh yeah all of the leather
yeah hey real quick yeah did you watch p
diddy host the billboard awards i did
not you didn't no because you're p diddy
right now because he was in the middle
of hosting the awards and then started
pitching his sorak vodka i don't want to
pitch this what i'm saying is what is
the uh because there's a whole point to
this what is what are these strategies
maybe rhino
yeah i think it's a reptile so maybe
like a snake okay toad okay
it's elephant from botswana who's gonna
say elephant too now people are going
brian you'd kill an elephant absolutely
no it's just from a baby uh snout these
are the custom-made straps why am i
wearing elephant it's the strongest
leather it'll last forever these are the
custom scraps now here's the thing about
elephant making a pair of these exact
ones for bradley martin and i will make
you a pair of tiger we got tiger prints
that i'm going to make for tiger because
you're all about tiger and your son
and they're going to be exactly like
this and i promise you'll wear them all
the time i'll wear those yeah yeah
they're awesome and you wear those on
stage remember that was my
recommendation i can't promote your to
promote your special in your sandals i
would i should it's your vibe daddy i
know i wear them all the time but i
don't want to wear them on my especially
i need that that's what makes you unique
no one's ever done it i just don't want
them looking at my at the toes and
thinking about my standup i want to wear
just regular neutral shoes i wore my
golden goose i bought some golden goose
that worked not bad now i i had uh you
know it stressed me out i couldn't be
there i was in philly great time but i
wish i was there but i had some birdies
in the crowd you had burnt some eyeballs
that's some eyeballs okay so it went
very well i heard that yes oh you had
you had eyeballs in minecraft oh yeah
yeah it went about probably 12 people
texting well i want to thank everybody
for coming out to the special because it
went it went really well uh you know
you're always nervous it's always like a
hard thing because you want to capture
everything get uh hmu
uh what's your hair makeup
you don't know that a little bit my girl
dusted my head she had your girl do it
she put the you know the little dusty
things that keep your hair from looking
bald and it actually worked what do we
do for the beard the beard i i was gonna
put a little mascara and i tried it oh
wow and it just didn't work and i was
like you know i'm going gray because
daddy's gray [ __ ] it yeah i would own
that the hair the hair i i get working
what was the outfit you didn't send me a
picture for approval black
i got a black long sleeve uh standard
true classic and they sound long sleeve
long sleeve and just uh a pair of dragon
bone jeans what color uh dark blue dark
blue and then green and white uh um
that's cool it was so sticky simple yeah
yeah exactly now before i wanted to say
this because i if i say i'm wearing
elephant i don't want people to think i
kill elephants so before you guys give
me a hard time somebody did you when you
have elephants they have to be culled
or they die of natural causes because
what happens is you can't have elephants
expand because they'll ruin everything
so when you're managing game that's why
you use and all the money that you use
for the
skin goes back directly back to
preserving elephant habitat and
elephants there so they take out the
bull
they take out yeah so any any time you
have like an old animal or you get like
an animal can no longer breed or they're
sick or they're wounded that when the
when game wardens kill a rhinos or any
of that [ __ ] either they'll give you a
tag to shoot it and then 300 grand of
that money goes directly back to paying
for it
they're in the [ __ ] they're in the
africa like this they go oh that
elephant sneezed get your gun out well
you know what we gotta make some sand
get your gun out that elephant has a
running that was a sneeze dude that was
a sneeze and then if i was ever like i
think it's algae's no no he's definitely
keep sniffling a little bit
you know what he has that new variant
yeah let's take him out
we're gonna make three thousand sandals
from his snack that's right and
personally i would never want to kill an
elephant even if it was i love elephants
i mean i just wouldn't get a thing off
of it i mean if i was doing it to
consume you know what they try to do
with elephants they try to uh sterilize
them so they'll dart them from a
helicopter enjoy that it's so expensive
and impossible that the only way to keep
elephants healthy and their populations
healthy is
to call them which is uh a youth and i a
euphemistic way of saying kill them
but you you have to because otherwise i
love elephants like dude you know how
like like if i love evelyn so much you
know like if you got bit by a
rattlesnake let's say it bit the middle
of your piece yeah dude i'm such a good
friend i would suck the venom out you
you know i took the venom out of my
piece i would appreciate it yeah so no
one's filming i would suck the venom out
because i don't want you to die would
you put it all the way because you have
to get deep down you have to tell me or
i do it like a subway like sandwich i
just go yeah and i feel like it hurts
working also yeah but also work the
balls finger my ass but then also i love
elephants so much i would if an elephant
was sick i would grab a snap
suck the sickness out of his snout i
appreciate that
i appreciate that that's why i can't
wear elephant sandals no but i'm gonna
make you make full elephant ice yeah
they also have full elefante but i and
they're all great do they have to be
gray like an elephant gray well no
because they have different colors it's
[ __ ] amazing isn't there white
elephants there's like one
you know those sandals would die that
[ __ ] we have white alligator
and white crocodile but aren't there
really albino crocodiles and alligators
yeah it's very hard to find but they can
do anything like there's this company
where they get all their skins from
american tan hides and tanning or
something and it's like the best there
is and you can get [ __ ] anything you
can do holy oh that's good but that's
not an albino that's a that's i think
dust that's dusty yeah it's like grayish
yeah yeah but it's fascinating i'm
learning a lot about conservation you're
talking about uh animals and skin and uh
conservative you uh are you the bad guy
from ace ventura too i don't know i know
just just i keep like a con a pet condor
a pet dolphin a pet panda and i bring a
bad guy from a mason shirt too and you
come to my house and i'm like would you
like some panda paws and i'm they died
of natural i'm the fat guy who uh helps
out uh ace ventura
oh there he is
yeah you're that guy maybe i'll grow a
thin mustache that's you i should grow a
thin mustache dude yeah there you are
wow a lot of actors you see and you
don't see them again it's weird you did
that one roll didn't he
yeah that's the way it is when it comes
to great role though man
maybe we got uh
or you just
just things happen
you know oh i would buy that but that's
cool was that signed by that guy or yeah
she never worked again really who's that
she oh she was in the first one yeah
dude ray finkel zeinhorn she was in she
was a star in the 90s and then oh really
yep sometimes they just quit though
she i guess
was
she made some mistakes she wanted to be
catwoman and the story goes that they
were like it's been cast and then she
landed a helicopter on the set dressed
as catwoman
she did something crazy like that big
risk like the director was like
it's cast this is great director was
like you look ridiculous yeah somewhere
also where'd you get all these cats yeah
just jumps out of the house with just
thousands of guys dude these cats don't
have homes well i remember she was a
huge star and then it the word got out
that she was quote unquote crazy which
she may not have been but she never
worked again she never lost that stigma
that [ __ ] it's like the amber heard
stuff like good luck getting work now
peloton take a break brian because you
know some chatty kathy's dude
i've been part of peloton for
six seven years now that's where you get
those juicy thighs well that's genetic
raindrops is it raining here nope it's
my quads it's quadzilla over here
quadzilla thanks to peloton i don't have
to hit the road where it's dangerous i
might get hit by a car
first pelleting workout this weekend oh
you didn't yes would you do 20 minutes i
did a 20 minute and it was all i [ __ ]
needed that's all you need dude you got
20 minutes sure you do do you want to go
to the gym anymore nope you work out for
home get a great workout we got you with
pelton dude world-class instructors
ready to motivate you 24 7. it's not
just cycling you've got strength
training you're going to do yoga you can
do running you can do boxing you knew
boxing that's what and it's so much fun
the best part about this for me dude i
crank it up the music is so freaking fun
man they got some bangers slappers for
days
maybe you're looking for a 10-minute
upper body stretch between calls or a 40
minute run before bed what's up man
pelton is there whenever you have time
there's no rush you got this get a great
workout in right now is the perfect time
to try peloton pelton bike plus is now
500 buckaroos less it's the best price
ever 500 including free delivery and
setup they set mine up is fantastic and
there are more game changing prices
available on the original pelton bike
which i have in the peloton tread that's
the treadmill visit onepeloton.com to
learn more you know i got to talk to you
about element for a second oh please
i mean l m n t not element but l m n
pronounced element yeah now listen
yeah you gotta you gotta get your
electrolytes we know i like to drink
dude i like to drink alcohol i'm on the
road i'm drinking i'm dehydrated yeah
you know the first thing i do when i
touch the ground i touch that sweet la
taxes through the gazoo la ground no
element i go element i gotta get into
your body water element boom i do it on
some days i'll go i'm 55 i'm gonna do
two workouts today i said it i gotta get
my electrolytes back
yeah dude pushing it i can't stop won't
stop you know this yeah dude i don't
judge i do i'm on stage for two hours
two and a half hours at my age i need i
need my electrolytes you're sweating
you're like cat wheeling you're sweating
this is no junk no sugar no coloring no
artificial ingredients no good
no fillers no bs one hot 1 000 milligram
sodium 200 milligrams potassium 60
milligrams magnesium those things you
are notoriously short on all the time
none of the junk no sugar no coloring
this just isn't for professional
athletes everyone moms dads nba nfl nhl
olympic athletes navy seals
dude if it's getting up for a navy seal
it's not good enough for your ass try it
though cause they'll give you money back
they're offering you a free element
sample pack eight single packet servings
free just cover the cost of shipping
five dollars for us customers get yours
at drink element lmnt.com
fighter the deal is not available on
their regular website so you got to go
to drink d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
dot com
fighter uh element offers no questions
asked refunds if you don't like it but
you're gonna love it so don't worry
about that try it risk free if you don't
like it share it with a salty friend and
we'll give you your money back no
questions asked you have nothing to lose
drink element dot com slash fighter
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
dot com
johnny huh because now they're saying
that he really embellished the the
finger
story because that expert was like
there's no way that it would work like
that but you but you can see there's
spoken holes in whatever here's the
bottom line guilty
they're both bat-shit crazy yes but you
can see like i was watching it because
i'm obsessed with it this is nice
you if you listen to the [ __ ] tapes
it's so clear that she was the initiator
of the violence
she
said it and then she goes no but that
was after he was beating me up well
there's no evidence to that if
somebody's hitting you repeatedly in the
face with rings on their fingers you'd
have a couple [ __ ] marks yeah but
it's but it's also like um you know she
was like yeah because johnny's done this
i've lost roles like my role in aquaman
two didn't see the director came out
he's like
she ain't losing because johnny depp
drama we don't care about that he goes
do we edit her out of the movie she's
barely in it because there was no
chemistry between her and jason mamoa
there you go oh well everyone loves
jason momoa who's the common denominator
that's causing all the issues when the
director goes man there's no this weird
vibe this isn't going to work this can
come off on on camera on the screen we
can't have that
i think that to me that's the biggest
thing if there's like oh yeah she's a
sociopath i think she's so full of [ __ ]
like i at one point i was like maybe
she's got mental illness and stuff as i
listen to it i think she's absolutely a
calculated liar across the board i
really do i think he's crazy i think he
was a nightmare i think he did drugs
he's a pain in the ass but the the act
the accusations that he raped me with a
wine baller i was bleeding out of my
vagina she said that or that he and he
repeatedly i lost her timing the timing
of it too like we're in the height of me
too takes this article out
she's just an opportunist like bad
person sociopath i've seen a million oh
by the way here's the other thing so she
wanted to keep the divorce settlement
secret huh well if somebody went into a
divorce okay
you don't have to go down there yourself
it's filed by a lawyer that's how
everybody does it you don't i would
never go down to the court she went down
to the courthouse
herself with her publicist you don't
think she called them
she [ __ ] up when she was on on on her
deposition so you're like
i mean you you're you're lying so badly
and you're getting caught it's just you
know just but just nonstop time after
time time after time and when you get
put up on the [ __ ] the like what
what's that saying when you tell the
truth you have to remember one story
when you lie you gotta remember all the
stories enjoy that [ __ ] what's funny is
uh johnny depp's lawyer pretty hot she's
becoming a superstar now the word on the
street is her and johnny well or a thing
i don't know how it couldn't be i don't
know how it couldn't be hey johnny how
fun are you in
with that by the way hey jack sparrow
yeah give us your take on things hey let
us know how that argument ends and by
the way he might be a great guy and a
great actor both of which are true but
he spent
you can tell me if i'm i'm going to make
a statement tell me if i'm a little over
the top please he spent 30 years at the
top of the hollywood pyramid
high
and drunk
every single [ __ ] day bro this is my
thing motivational at this point i mean
you can do all the cocaine all the booze
and all the opiates and still crush it
at a high level
he looks better than i do he's 60. he
looks better than both of us right dude
how about this how to your point raging
alcoholic
uh addicted to opiates
crushing it crushed listen you can
listen to tony robbins he's great you
listen to gary vee or you can get
motivated by freaking johnny depp dude
and still showed up still looking like a
dying piece you see he's a man gypsy
okay dude he's a sexy gypsy
and he will wear it he will wear i you
know your boy is jared leto that's your
north star
but you got to give it up to johnny
better okay
now you're you would make it careful
careful i don't know i'm totally nice
are you coming off the special feeling
good hold on
hold on don't go bad on i'm not gonna do
that don't do that i got i'm gonna get
you jared leto at 35. he's all done up
take it easy i know you're getting
harder hold on 50 years old i'm let me
go i'm we're in a time machine i'm going
to put you in a time machine okay cool
now and i want you to think about this
don't be don't be don't jump now i got
jared leto i'm putting him in a [ __ ]
time machine okay he's 35.
i saw him in vegas at 35. yeah his hair
is so silky his skin is so beautiful
he's he's like a wine he's better when
so you like him older oh right now he's
the best he's ever okay so i got your
letter now i got your daytona i got
johnny depp when he was 35. oh yeah
agree 100 no no 100 now i thought we're
going to fight no now doesn't mean
johnny does now they're both there who
who do you make out with first
you have to be in a relationship with
them and you're straight but if you're
in a relationship that's not gay so you
gotta you gotta you gotta make out with
either one who's saying johnny depp at
35 look at him look at that dude come on
come on come on come on
come on so he can't do a little opiate
and pass out from time to time so he
can't wear mascara dude and talk like a
pirate even though he's from kentucky
all i'm saying is keep the ecstasy and
the booze away from me because i'm going
to be and even the blow because i'm
going to be excited and if he goes and
if he moves in on me i might i might
have to meet him halfway go to that far
right one chin that's him young now
dude tell me he hasn't aged like jesus
he's he's fashioned jesus right there he
couldn't look better he's fashioned
jesus he's fascinating my thing is me
and him we're a couple dude what am i
gonna win you don't say like i'm just
wearing a basic suit and he's in
feathers dude i'm gonna tell you what
you wear and i'm not trying to be you
know gag ball chain well where are you
going with this
hi we're in the same bathroom i got you
dressed like [ __ ] barney rubble
you're wearing a leather one-piece woman
you're the caveman you're the big old
cake i'm a bat mm-hmm i'll throw you in
some custom-made toe holds okay all
right i i gotta i'll get some skins on
you and now you're i'm fred flintstone
[ __ ] i know that but bubba you're
gonna but you have to be around dude if
this is the cartoon fred flintstone yeah
you're was it barney rebel yeah i'm fred
flintstone and he's the dinosaur
[Laughter]
randomly like it was like so out of
nowhere he was like dude dude to the
whole group i figured out it's uh that's
a t-shirt that's a t-shirt mark is an
animal from the muppets dude that's a
t-shirt
mark's that mark's martino there's the
three of us barney rubble mark's bigger
than all of us there's the three of us
wow we've got to gray up uh barney's
hair all right i look exactly like fred
flintstone that's fine and that's mark
now it's mark mark mark is you know
mark's a ball of energy mark does not
stop talking 24 7. flexible too yeah
sure whatever weird but the thing is he
doesn't yeah weird he does not stop
talking and i love him for it he's the
best got a good social media dude he's
over i'm like enough dude enough this
isn't a reality show this in the
kardashians we're good we checked the
box mark we're good
i realized last night it hit me i went
oh
mark is the animal for muppet babies
you know the guy who's the the muppet
who's just out of control yeah he's an
animal dude mark is an animal i don't
get this from mark oh dude you get a zen
vibe no no no no mark is if you click on
it the animal just everyone's chilling
the animals comes in his hair's wild i
don't get that oh you know
daddy i get man lion i get man i got i
get man lion who who has a a deep
baritone voice
who is who is there chin the the go to
the far left on the original dude down
no go down no down down down that one
that's mark but bubba that guy's a sharp
f mark's not a sharp f
no it's not he's mark's just wild dude
yeah and his hair is all crazy that's
mark it's on the road
but it's fine i'm kermit the frog but
it's fair to say mark mark has a lot of
social intelligence so he always knows
how high so he's never he's never like
uh he's never overbearing or he knows
how to play the game he's just loud
like on the plane i don't know i don't
need to be like hey mark are you 28 f
i'll hear him oh i'm like oh
he's not talking to anybody he's just
laughing his ass off at a video on world
star something or the guy next to him
that he just met he's this loud all the
time so on saturday on saturday saturday
you know how it goes yeah saturday i
knew i [ __ ] thursday crowd one of the
top five crowds i've ever had friday
popping i go
saturday's gonna be rough philly's known
for being rough i warned every comic on
the lineup even the kid i give an
opportunity to i went i did an
appearance at suplex they go man this
kid he's only 24. um his name's connor
great kid
connor mook great kid he uh i meet him
whatever he's such a nice guy he goes
yeah you know i'm grinding man three
years i do i run my own show here um i
i'm a regular at the helium i opened up
for um
you know you name it i open up for uh
shane gillis i'll but i go do you have
uh five minutes and he goes i'll have a
clean five minutes and clean to me and
tell me if i'm off on this clean to me
goes i go clean what are you getting
ready to do the tonight show are you
doing clean do you i go do you have
dirty [ __ ] he goes oh no i don't mean
like clean no cussing or dick talk i'm
talking like clean like a fire five and
i said cool man what are you doing
tonight he's like i don't know trying to
find spots i went i'm gonna give you a
five minute spot on the sold out show on
the saturday show on saturday night show
he's like really i'm like yeah man
but i told everyone the green room i
said it's saturday night philly
they are notoriously known
you're we're lion tamers here's the
problem we don't have our whip
and these lions been drinking well and
these lions are blue collars and they
outnumber us so when you go out there
have your mind so first show kid crushes
it he said oh my thank you give me hugs
like it
dude
this second show ain't gonna go like
that we're starting at ten starting at
ten thirty huge mistake which really
means you start at 11 which really means
i've been drinking since seven so i mean
daddy gets on stage at midnight midnight
at midnight that's a problem because
they're not they're so drunk in that
packed room it was a it was the purge
sir
the walking dead yes now my boy connor
the second set
they're not even listening to i didn't
go i told him i said i'm telling you so
then david goes out there and i said
connor watch man this is how you deal
with it if you let them keep going
they're gonna just you're laying line
tamer the line has taken over you got to
get the power back david goes out there
and there's just a group in the middle
just these guys just would not so you
know david professional roaster
[ __ ] all material and just go for he did
15 minutes at 10 to 12 minutes it was
just him
lightening them the [ __ ] up resets the
room yep then i get out there they're
still a little loud the guy in the front
lit him up we're on camera good time
we'll post it but then that they know oh
oh i bet my bat that's right do you
think that's right we're here to listen
to you but do you feel like they see
your size also though and they're a
little bit more respectful naturally
no i've had problems before for sure no
because for me
philly i don't know if you remember this
the first one of the first live shows we
ever did
was i think at the trucker darrow or
something oh you're right or was it the
830 club it was i i look up at this he
was if it's trucking there in philly
that's what it was anyway we do that and
you because you were from colorado and
stuff it's not like you don't know
aggressive people but i remember you
went hey dude this is actually a little
scary philly crowds are aggressive as
[ __ ] that's right we did dude that was
that was it and and it got so out of
control i remember i think we did two
shows that you were like jesus christ
this is kind of crazy now i was at
helium on a saturday in philly uh yep uh
about five years ago i don't know if you
remember this but number one i had to
break up a fight because the gal and a
guy came up and the gal was like she was
like she was built very well and she had
her butt out or something and the guy
goes grab it grab it and the dude who is
big with her goes hey guys
be nice i'll say it once hey is this you
you're on stage or something i'm taking
pictures after the show oh gotcha hey
guys be nice lisa's after be nice i'm
asking i'm asking nicely big guy oh yeah
but those other two guys were big but it
was such a standoff and i was like hey
hey everybody okay let's take a picture
let's move on because it could have gone
south so quick and then
i got my pocket picked i don't know if
you remember i lost i i lost like 300
dollars that was in my [ __ ] pocket
cash jesus christ so somebody was taking
a picture with me and somebody's
somebody had sticky fingers good for
them i don't know how much i lost i
can't remember i went on the radio show
the next day you talked about it pick
pockets taking pictures yeah dude
is it is it 1905 who's pickpocket yeah
have you ever seen the best guys do it
before because i've watched some videos
it's incredible they'll steal your watch
pocket they'll still they'll see my
watch and you don't even know because
they what they do is they distract you
yeah they'll hit your other part of your
body and then you're not so when when a
magician takes your watch they that's
what they're doing yeah yeah they're
playing with your distraction like what
the [ __ ] you know
um yeah philly is uh awesome but 10 30.
it's too late because they don't you
don't get started until at least eleven
but the best part is i uh friday night
show i get a text from shane gillis he
goes what are you doing i said you know
what i'm doing i'm in your hometown are
you where are you at new york he's from
philly he's born and raised
he came up in the philly scene oh wow
yeah he's great him and kevin hart i
mean you know what i'm saying like
philly has some monster comics so i know
shane lives in new york area where i go
you know where i'm at dude i'm in your
hometown and he goes yeah cool man
everybody in new york is no because he
shoots that show shane and gilly or
whatever his his uh you know show
he goes no we shoot that in philly i'm
here all weekend and he goes i'm at a
bar i didn't know this bar stool has
their own bars
barstool sports yeah so my boys at
barstool kevin and all those boys were
all there with shane wow and you know i
never go out especially in philly yeah
but they're like you gotta come by for
one drink so i mean the squad go there
for one drink me and shane had a drink
posted the pic i was like dude you're
you're not a bad looking dude you don't
have to look like that bring that pick
up chin it's on my instagram he thinks
it's so funny he goes he goes listen
dude i get annihilated people make fun
of my looks anyways
uh go up chin
the one with shane kills there you go
look at him big guy
yeah he was giving me [ __ ] what do you
mean because he doesn't work out or
something is that what you're saying
what do you mean you say you don't have
to look that way what do you mean
he's not a bad looking guy but he wants
to make that face so he looks like
peanut butter falcon oh because he goes
he goes i'm taking the power from
they're gonna make fun of the way i look
anyway you're not bad looking guy dude
and i said and then as i'm leaving i go
now are you gonna be on gq no that's not
for you that's not your path yeah but
you're not battling i never i never
looked at him and thought him as a bad
look no he was funny because when i was
on uh
rogan rogan was you know shane's an
athlete manchester and i go whoa athlete
what do you guys think
he was we played college football go and
he only played a year and then he'd
stopped doing it he's like well no he's
working he's getting big i go man you
know me that's triggering with athlete
thing but shane was like dude people hit
me up about rogan he's like you're right
i played one year at one double a and
quit dude yeah he's like someone say
after i'm like yeah you know i'm not
busting your bottom you're [ __ ] dude
no but i'm just saying it's like there's
just different levels to it so yes you
know it's just different levels
i'm with you man yeah i agree with you
dude yes you look great though yeah now
he pounds bears like he's [ __ ] al
bundy yeah you know like you don't know
anybody it drinks bear like him like
when he's coming to l.a he was doing our
show remember he's touring for a special
wednesday night seven o'clock
hey bro meet me at the sports bar yeah
during the nfl season let's watch the
game tonight and have some beers
i'm a dad some people can't do sports
some people can drink like and they are
100 we need to [ __ ] we need to save
shane gillis at all costs he's the last
like a mer like hardcore like american
dad energy even though he doesn't have
kids yeah he's just that like
mowing the lawn doesn't [ __ ] how he
dresses yeah dresses like like a billy
gardel billy garcia dresses like the
offense coordinator for a high school
football team you know like sweats
sandals thinking about [ __ ] yeah yeah
don't care about anything i was talking
about what do you do you know he's
selling tickets daddy and it shows you
thank you youtube thank you youtube
special yeah man he's crushing it that's
why i told him i said you gave me the
confidence to put mine on youtube man
like you were the you and mark norton
were the first ones like i'm not
reinventing the wheel here yeah you guys
saw how many views you got i'm like but
that's more you can get on netflix
uh where like 1.2 million now damn
should it shoot amazing hit on track to
do it right around over 2 million i love
it yo i was telling you i didn't
reinvent the wheel like you guys gave
him the inspiration man like i can't
thank you enough yeah
you know i was thinking about this you
put it on netflix um as well it's like
david spades and stuff like that it gets
lost in the shuffle man it gets lost
it's like unless it's like trending like
crazy like the good thing the best deal
i've ever heard
is krista stefano special especially
weshi it's trending on netflix but it's
only i think 26 minutes long or 36
minutes long the rest of it is on
youtube so you're checking the box with
netflix then you're also checking the
box with your audience on youtube yep
he's brilliant
that's the best way to do it i told i
text uh the stuff oh i saw him in person
in new york thomas said
what do you think four months before i
uh i can't call you direct anymore i've
talked to an assistant he's like no
never i'm like what are you such a good
guy six months
the best [ __ ] guy well for me for my
special my first the first time i shot
60 minutes the second time i shot 78
minutes only because i wanted to get
everything so you can chop it up yeah i
just want all of it i just want all of
the material so i can just use it and
put it out there yeah you know yeah if
it's seven eight minutes i mean
those those 18 minutes you can chop up
as you know short bits to promote that
exactly yeah that is going to help right
mm-hmm yeah i told you i got you yeah i
hate i wasn't there dude i hate it i'm
so stressed but daddy had birds in the
audience yeah all of them said it was
great man all of them thanks buddy
apparently you had some rant on
something and then you're like that's
not making this special yeah you know
there's so much that you have said
you're like doing like a long story
about this yeah and people love it at
the end you're like yeah everybody's
like put it in and i was like i can't
you know but it'll be out there
i would take it out and then after the
special if it's like a long story form
then after you post it exactly bonus
content exactly i realized how much i'd
written over the past like two years as
crazy as it's been um i just kept
putting my energy into it you know and
uh
you know i think i've told you this
before and i think you and i have been
talking about this a lot too no matter
what happens to you man no matter what
happens to you i think like if something
really bad whatever it might be your job
is if you survive it to orchestrate your
life so that five years later you
wouldn't change it because it it made
you a better person it made you a better
comic it made you a better business man
it made you a better person yeah your
experience yeah life experience
priceless priceless right yeah my new
thing is and mark knows this more than
anyone is when i was in charlotte
i was just talking to you know the the
guys jay and david and justin i was just
talking to them and i was talking about
muggsy bogues and how he should do this
and this and this and then they were
dying laughing i was like oh dude
there's something here oh yeah sorry now
so i went so i got the idea i was like
oh i i hired a videographer and i was
like oh i'm gonna post this just says
throw away because you never use
charlotte material specific suppose it
and then after i was like oh
for every city
when i get to the green room i'm gonna
write a bit for everything i'm gonna
kick off every single show because this
stuff i'm gonna do this the flow thing
i've been thinking so i just so i did it
for philly about ben franklin which
we're gonna post this week yeah yeah i
went hard i love that you're doing this
i went hard on the paint on ben franklin
and but then also right for me like the
narrative of this toxic reddit i talked
about ben franklin's like dark history
and i go you're not going to learn about
this in a textbook i go i found this on
ben franklin's reddit and i go you think
mine is toxic look at ben franklin's
subreddit it is bad
the crowd
dying because itself in the room they
know what's up so of course it's just
dude that's great just poking holes dude
i i was i gotta tell you that kid loved
what you did and i had some some eyes in
the crowd
and they said that you did some [ __ ]
i think they said the saturday first
show or something was you were like you
were it was unbelievable dude i did a
hundred all right i decided again again
dude again
i did 120 minutes yeah again
really
i love you for that look at because
someone yelled out somebody amber heard
and i went what'd you say
and then i had like just riffing five
six minutes on amazon so so
yeah dude so whatever goes on whatever
negativity
goes on
it just makes you better because now you
go oh oh really oh you know what cool
thank you for that thank you yeah you're
helping thank you
now i will now i will let me see if i
can prove you all wrong that's all and
that's all you can do yeah yeah and i i
i think it was nietzsche who said
if i ever have children i wish for them
conflict loss
controversy and an obstacle abster after
obstacle it is the only way you will you
will become a fully realized human being
who understands themselves
and as i get older those are gifts there
are not they are nonsense demons they're
angels they're not demons yep i'm
[ __ ] serious man maybe that's where
religion comes from i'm wearing [ __ ]
nobody has talked about how [ __ ]
beautiful my lilac sweatshirt is dude i
do like the color fairly colorful today
dude i bought a hoodie yesterday
from the this uh i was at the mall i see
the storm i've never heard of that so i
went and talked to this lady she was she
was like probably your age but dressed
like a [ __ ] boy like fly yeah she looked
good yeah you know older and i
appreciate that and i was like what is
this store she goes oh it's me and my
husband's we start in new york it's all
uh sourced and handmade in l.a and i was
like oh you're because i run a merch
business i was like you know we have to
outsource not in america i was like so
your margins are must be insane she's
like it's so expensive around l.a but
we're providing jobs in la that's why we
do it we have this vision i was like
dude i'm in man
i bought this hoodie that is going to
offend you so bad yeah it looks like i'm
wearing a cape really it's short in the
front and then
there's a long
tape in the back i know
that's annoying when she pulled out she
was the only uh
thing that we have that will fit you
right now because we sell out of our
bigger size so fast after so number one
seven hundred i have one in the back she
just has kind of a cape thing on it went
you say cape she was yelling
all right i'll see it she brings out and
my girl goes no i'll take it excuse me
i'm gonna try it on you i love kate does
it come with a falcon oh it'd be sick
it comes with eyeliner
that was so so wait about it so better
fashion
johnny depp jared leto oh jared leto all
day really yeah he's the face of [ __ ]
gucci yeah johnny depp's more john i
don't know anyone who looks at johnny
like i want to dress like jack sparrow
you know what i'm saying i don't know
how that kid looks that good at 50 in
his 50s it's crazy
ah
jeanette's a [ __ ] i saw him at a
party and i was like in person he was
like magical magical it's a unicorn you
look 35 no
i'm not gay man but i always say i'm not
a gay man but you bring him around dude
i don't know what happens you don't know
what happened tiger tiger thick is
flowing he shows up and he's like this
whiskey what is this a blend of bourbon
and american bourbon and japanese
whisking you go yeah and then he goes
nobody's ever done that before and i'd
say your palate man this is insane
that's what i've been here 50 years by
man
what
yeah and he goes dude you've seen my
room i'm like
no why would i see your room he goes
come check it out i would walk down here
is that a water bet he is the last one
they make man then he goes like this he
goes she gave that to him what's going
on with your ear that's a gucci
waterproof with your ears in your arm
he's like
he scared me he's like you're
frightening and i go dude what's that
waterbed it doesn't look like water yeah
he's like it's actually kool-aid you
like kool-aid right yep i love kool-aid
goes go and suck on that thing get some
kool-aid out man then we're sipping cool
like i'm sipping then he goes hey you
know what's [ __ ] he goes your lips
are all red and i look you're silly man
he goes yours are red and he's like do
you look ah
and then you hear this i don't hear that
hear this
and you look over and old rings he's
crouched with his big old balls just
jacking it
look at that
yeah but your tongue is red from
drinking the kool-aid and then yeah that
and he's like
who's that i'm like that's my keeper
it's my key that's my handler that's my
keeper and then we call him the [ __ ]
i can fix this brian face the wall then
you just see me face the wall crowd and
you see my [ __ ] yeah just my balls
and it's just you keep hearing
and that's just you going yep and he
goes he's just gonna do that all and i
go all night daddy he's 60. dick could
cut a diamond yeah look at them big
balls jared they're getting bigger great
look at that gray asshair then i'm going
to say hey jade well you tell me if this
is out of line it's your place man
that's your water bed i'm a fan
is it cool if he dips his nuts in the
kool-aid
and we suck on them they're just
dragging on the floor
my nuts are just tragic on the car just
an idea here you've been running the
ship this whole time and i'm i'm on
board dude are you cool if the old man
drops his nuts in your kool-aid water
bed might not know we might not see
anything they suck on them is that weird
they're sitting on the oak floor and i
go is this spanish oak my balls are
sensitive
they got feelers i don't want any
splinters jared i i got a splinter in my
sack i'm gonna have to break you guys up
i need you to get some tweezers and then
jared's gonna say are you wearing my
gucci scarf i'm like yeah i found the
closet because i've been in there this
whole time i've been in there i saw you
guys making it out man noodling around
and then you go here's where it gets
dicey jared i hate to do this and i'm
not gonna do it if you let me dip my
nuts in your kool-aid water bed this is
a ridiculous story
dip my nuts in your kool-aid water bed
but i shot video of you in the big man
wrestling wrestling wrasse and what's
going on in the olsen doing the old
pornographic grapple yeah yeah the old
cinemax showdown yup yup i saw you guys
doing that now i'm gonna go live with
this if you don't give me 20 million
dollars that's it yeah there you go and
then you and i right and
your wardrobe because i'm changing my
look and we fixed oh you could fit it
dude we're the same size yep and now i
every day i show up in [ __ ] jared
leto's wardrobe but then but then jared
rose you online and he goes uh those are
old clothes that i wore when i played
that transgender with aids
i was 90 pounds you won an oscar yep
good enough for me it doesn't fit me
anymore that's from my old wardrobe you
have my jean shorts on when i played a
transgender and dallas buyers joke's on
me
i like that that story ended with
blackmail and then getting roasted for
wearing a transgender clothes
from dallas that was amazing we had to
represent every that was an incredible
journey hey guys straight guys trans
guys who had the trans people
double dipping your nuts and kool-aid
yeah that's good too there's a lot of
great images in that thanks buddy thanks
man heavy nuts nothing no better image
than me as uh fred flint soap barney
rebel and the dino uh-huh
does he look like dino that would be
merch dude i don't think that way i'm so
happy with his arms in that pink shirt
in that pink shirt did you so you didn't
know that he was wearing he was going
pink up top no yeah i didn't even know
it this was not planned and then here's
the thing look at mark and chin's
kicks oh
yep oh talk to me about the kicks
because those are those from suplex
bless you yeah i went to supalex they
hooked the entire team up jay got some
dope kicks i hear some kicks that are
gonna piss you off brian really
uh yeah let me see him can i see a pic
uh bring up travis scott jordan ones jen
i put the pink laces in there what are
those
the uh i just i i won these off the
night yet do you not wear tokyo do you
not wear socks with most of your shoes
sorry i'm sorry sorry what do i know
i apologize are these ones those are
nice though
i'm not mad at those uh the blue ones
blue ones yeah those are it
hey uh suplex i need a pair of ten and a
half
those are about nine grand sir they are
yeah i didn't pay that for them why are
they so expensive
is this just so rare but they see all
the checks backwards
oh it's a travis scott
yeah
wow nike allows that
dude you have to collab with nike yeah
nike did that yeah nine grand sir mm-hmm
um for the size i don't know what about
what's mark's sporting right now you're
gonna tell me what these are i had no
idea i just said i picked out a couple
and said do you have these at a 13 and
he said no i was going for like either
these nice running shoes potentially uh
like air max
some new balance yeah and those are
those
those are jordans i believe yeah i don't
have the context to understand this
because as i've said before i only
purchased a skate shoe called es
sneakers and when i said that in a story
the owner reached out was like we'll
hook you up and i was like this is the
most affirming moment of my life yeah
this i think these are cool though those
are so sick those just came out those
are hard to get those are not 13. no
they are because like after he didn't
have the first couple yeah i was like
tell you what just whatever you got in
13 you picked something for me and he
came out with these and i was like i
really like the way those look and then
david lucas was like man you don't want
those yeah dave was trying to get bugs
for him hey that's my impression of mark
at a sneaker shop
can i deadlift in these and they're like
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know dude
every shirt can i deadlift from these i
don't know man these are [ __ ]
sneakers that's my only matrix for
understanding it's like there's a lot of
colors going on i don't know because
there's such a difference in value
between different like imagine you don't
know anything about jordans and you walk
in you're just like
how am i developing these you know how
am i categorizing it's like with wine
it's like bee with wine how many good
wines are there and then you're like i
guess i'll take this one someone's like
dude that's a three thousand dollar
bottle of wine you don't know shoes i
can't
go like this is the two hundred dollar
one this is the five right that would be
me too because i told him that mike at
suplex i was like dude you don't waste
you know i don't know anything so i just
wanted and then they just randomly pick
out a shoe for chin and chin i i love
his [ __ ] interaction
those are cool issues now here's the
thing about chimps those are max 90s
yeah really cool those are great kicks
i love them where they had houndstooth
on them all right he said rubber gum
bottoms yeah the bottoms are called
gumbo but there's hounds through them
i'm pretty sure they're expensive and
they're fluorescent here
now here's the thing about chin and
philly
chin was not sober one minute in
philadelphia i was on vacay
you were drunk not drunk but i was not
sober wow i was just enjoying my time
there yeah it was great did you guys
philly stake it up yep yeah it did there
was one right around the corner one and
a half yeah it's philly steakhouse or
something like that now what did you do
for breakfast you didn't eat breakfast
oh come on dad you know i don't eat
about two three yeah now i'm eating
today stick to your carnivore diet
uh no because i had a piece of pizza at
suplex which breaks it and then i had
half of uh philly cheesesteak nothing
wrong other than that yeah stuck to it
nothing wrong with that yeah again i'm
about 96
percent carnivore no carbs i had all i
had was but people are getting upset
when doing the ingredient like dude what
the [ __ ] thick boy yeah i'm like no
there you go what's your diago stress
hey b let's take a little break dude to
keep the house lights onto think boys
studios you're going to be in west palm
beach this weekend weekend dude in june
i am in portland in july
or also in june i'm in san francisco
then july i'm going to be in san diego
and then we're adding another fun date
there but portland you're up next
collins and palm beach palm beach yes
it's great man get your tickets at t fat
kz f a t k z dot com pkkc.com or brian
from epicboy.com listen dude but this
absolutely sponsored by real ketones not
fake ketones real ketones their product
is specifically bhb is the most
incredible wellness tool on the market
because it's hard to stay in ketosis
right and you try to be as ketosis as
you can so you need a little help oh
that's the biggest issue dude check this
out that's why i love this within one
hour you are in ketosis that jacks up
your metabolism gives you sustainable
energy it's the most powerful fuel for
your brain lose weight
yeah man
listen my favorite product is the prime
shift raspberry lemonade comes in a
bunch of amazing flavors all right
listen we recommend lean for life which
is the bhp ketones plus mct perfect for
someone who is on keto they also have
bhp capsules do when you have to go do
it man use promo code shop for 10 off
your first purchase at real ketones dot
com dude if you're a keto kid i'm
telling you boy d kitty it's tough to
get in ketosis this gets you within
ketosis within an hour dude plus if you
sign up for a monthly subscription
you're gonna save 20 off the normal
pricing every single month all right you
gotta go to
dot com all right promo code is shob
s-h-a-b ten percent off gets you
shredded get you shredded keto kid i'm
gonna buy half a cow and i'm gonna deep
freeze it i'm gonna get a grass-fed cow
i'm looking into it hey i'm gonna kiss
him hey bore quit killing animals wow
hey quit killing animals hey bad guy
from mr intruder too i quit killing
these animals i gotta have
i know i got to know where my cow comes
from bro
i bought a gallon cup in college because
trying to gain weight for the nfl but a
straight of a cow yeah not like a live
one
from a butcher i'm like hey i need all
the meat i'm trying to put on weight for
the nfl and i had t-bones fillets
you know how much did you eat you were
just eating crazy
non-stop like potato potatoes that rice
what i do i boil
like
nine cups of rice and then just eat rice
and red meat can you eat you can eat a
lot if you really want to yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah that's
certain things too like that after his
ice cream my girl last night was you've
been home you can cheat on your diet
because i've been good i was good all
day even on the plane i didn't touch
anything nothing and then she gave me
good this american idol finale like the
good point it's our favorite show it's
coming to an end and so she got a pint
of my favorite ice cream from afters
afterwards
great [ __ ] ice cream i'm a jenny's
guy doing they have jenny's is great too
yeah and there's salt and straw yeah
yeah if you're not if you don't might be
a little sweet if you don't eat three of
these it's ice cream though right so
sweet is what we want right yeah yep
that's afters that's afters oh boy that
looks like just that crazy [ __ ] that
they do yeah well i don't do all the
crazy [ __ ] but they have like a cookie
monster flavor that's the blue one right
blue for cookie monster they have uh the
best flavors but they have this coffee
one my girl got a pint of it yeah i ate
my dinner which was carnivore i just had
steak for dinner and i went you got the
ice cream shoes i got it just for you
because i only want a relaxed night and
i went oh you bought a pint why would
you do that because i thought you loved
it i i go i do but you don't realize
you're dealing with an addict and i have
four cavities which i gotta still call
your guy i have two weeks off from the
road so i'm gonna get fixed this week
let's go daddy can do it call him up
so when i eat ice cream i eat it like an
old man with no teeth i have to suck on
it so i can't touch the back teeth
i sucked on the entire pint like it was
jared leto's nuts yeah dropped in
[ __ ] kool-aid yeah the entire car
good call back thank you sir deep call
back dude the entire pint daddy ate all
of it
and you you so the reason
do you know why sugar does that to your
cavities my dentist told me because i
told him you were having that yeah what
do you say
it it creates acid
sugar mixed with saliva i guess creates
an acid and if you have an exposed nerve
that acid goes right to that [ __ ] oh
that's interesting
yeah it creates an acidic that's why
your teeth get rotten with sugar
because it creates a [ __ ] acidic
compound bro
it if it hits those horrible yeah some
of the worst pain in the world yes
that's correct that is correct that is
there's nothing worse than getting your
teeth drilled when it'll cut right now
i'm gonna i'm gonna call you guys to
schedule something i have to uh enough's
enough dude that's enough and you're
probably gonna have to get yourself into
some invisalign
no i don't care about them being
straight let me see i just don't want
him to hurt let me see
your teeth the problem is your bite is
your your bite's off and it's gonna cost
you you're never gonna fix that you can
do it you can too much work
yeah i'm i got two more teeth is what's
going to end me my teeth i know that's
not what's going to take daddy out
that's not the nail in the cockpit
daddy's not worried daddy's six four
yeah 2
4 right now not bad yeah dude not bad
skinny two four four six four two
forty six
that's impressive
so two four four don't eat alcoholic
that's fine but also not eating carbs
and that's important um and you are
sucks on ice cream and you eat suck on
ice cream but it's gonna be fun to be
able you'll get that [ __ ] fixed right
away they'll fix those teeth
and you in and out right easy work
and you know it's gonna be a little
while now listen you're gonna
yeah it's going to suck yeah the good
thing is i don't go through a teeth
clean because i did that like three
weeks ago yeah he's not gonna he's not
gonna you're just gonna have to he's he
better be gentle dude because anybody
who's who can he's like anal for the
first time be gentle daddy give me some
poppers and i'll pick a spot on the wall
go to town yeah put me under dude that's
it
and you'll be fine i'm i'm very
confident you'll be fine i'll be there
to hold your hand oh god all right chin
what do you got dude
all righty
uh we'll start off with some of the
marks
uh-oh uh-oh let's see what we have here
the gila mod there we go
oh what the [ __ ]
the the this stork got a nose job do you
know the details on this mark
um
i can read it if you want yeah good okay
all right so a stork was given a special
delivery it received a new beak
sometimes they do this they like they
mold stuff to you know an animal has a
limb missing or a thing missing i just
thought this is pretty cool um it
damaged its beak in an accident and
required anyone it was taken to
uh hordo baggy birds hospital 111 miles
east of the capital of budapest the
bird's beak was repaired by a
veterinarian thomas cothe who rebuilt
the bottom beak and made an entirely new
top part i know they did that
yeah they can grow bladders now and they
can grow an ear on they can grow guy
grew a dick on his own arm right yeah we
saw that yeah that's the new frontier
that's the new frontier
tissue regeneration is everything but
that uh that stork they just fix it up
and then it goes out in the wild
is it like the first chick to get a nose
job like his other friend like jesus
christ dude probably no your nose looks
ridiculous yeah quality life though your
beak looks insane gary yeah right yeah
your beak is dude can they have
taken a little bit off the top yeah you
have the same size beak as this where
are you fooling yeah you're not feeling
anybody it's like an 8 or 2 the thing
doesn't even look like a nose
you're saying the same color gary and
his friends lying to him you think like
no it looks great no he did keep gary
away from gary you're being sweet your
face is ours is orange yours is green
you have a green beak dumbass yeah
that's pretty cool i didn't know they
could do that for animals it's it's uh
heartwarming for me because i'm like oh
that that bird's life was terrible
before oh i have a question yeah i mean
brian was going to kill him sandals yes
skin you don't have stork though no but
we have osha skewed uh flip-flops quick
idea yeah for people that have babies
yeah the gift is using some stork
sandals not a bad idea dude light blue
light blue with bunny layers
which means that's a good idea in french
now bubba wait story i want to get your
take let's kill him i want to get your
take everybody's take on
jordan peterson went bad on the si
swimsuit cover model
which you know didn't need to be done
what do you think of that
uh can you give me a synopsis of what he
said uh he said this is not beauty
because
it's a big thick girl like you know not
even like like yeah like lizzo vibe you
know what i'm saying like
if i'm jordan and i i do i really enjoy
jordan peterson my thing is with jordan
peterson you know we have same agent so
you know he's very close to them justin
so
i go the only caveat i have here is like
not the fight to pick right but my thing
is like a lot of your fans
probably aren't going to win the olympia
either dude so they might be out of
shape so i think the way if you want to
say oh why are we promoting this
he says sorry not beautiful and no
amount of authoritarian tolerance is
going to change that cool i know so many
dudes and girls who like big guys i
agree yeah like they love them that's
their vibe personally yeah so for jordan
he's just been like man to me
this is in beauty yeah god bless the
rest of you that dig this yeah but to my
thing is to criticize her cool that's
you you want to do that you your thing
but then then to go talk or uh uh
twitter's so toxic i'm out no no no no
no you don't get to post this hateful
[ __ ] that's good and then when the game
gets gnarly yo get out
like if you're gonna give it you gotta
be able to take it as a huge fan of
jordan peterson i think this was this
kind of missed the mark i don't think it
was necessary i think what he was
talking about was
woke culture she's pretty high that's my
other thing she ain't that a lot of guys
that find this very attractive right
yeah she's very strong she is actually
very beautiful she's just
bigger and some men a lot of men like
this a lot of men so i i you know i was
going to say there's a legit there like
it's a conscious progressive attempt to
manipulate and retool the notion of
beauty relying on the idiot philosophy
that such preferences are learned and
properly changed by those who know
better so one of the things about
scientists that they have i told you
that they've done is that even
congenitally blind men have never seen a
woman when you have them touch a woman
with the 70 30 ratio hip to
waist ratio they prefer that and there
are certain
standards of beauty that cut across all
cultures um proportion yeah um um
symmetry even infants will stare at a
symmetrical phase longer than they would
otherwise yeah
that's more like open to attractive
people men women they've done studies
women prefer the smell of men who are
more symmetrical after they sweat
they've done all these studies the
science is not the science is not very
complementary to woke ideology
personally though
i i don't have a problem with s i
putting her on the cover because
you know there are people that consider
that beautiful i think she's actually
very beautiful she's sexy i think she
says i think jordan's off on this one
yeah i do too i think he should have put
out the twigo not my preference i'd be
worried about her cholesterol or
diabetes down the road sure if we want
to keep marketing that this is how
everybody should look yeah i don't agree
with it but let let that's good that
choice i mean if people are going to buy
the magazine or not and so for me this
is clearly an obesity issue in america
sure but this she's not obese no she's
not obese i don't and maybe her insides
are fine she'll have blood pressure
she's vegetarian whatever she's just a
big girl but to say she's not pretty
yeah
there are a lot of there's a lot of
women that probably appreciate the fact
that you know because it's really hard
being really heavy in a look i i want to
get your take on this too actually i
want to get your take on this yeah so
the kardashians
the amount of plastic surgery they've
had they start to look all the same
right and a lot of women look up to that
i don't think they look the same i don't
think they look the same i've seen them
in person i don't think they're the same
i do think they're very attractive now
they've had a lot of work done that's
right which isn't the the the message
you want to give to young girls okay so
that's what i'm saying it doesn't feel
like health but also but it feels like
that's more of a problem than s i
putting a woman like this on nobody
beautiful
i don't have both of them there's no
problem the problem comes down to the
parents where it's like if your kid's so
insecure your kid look because kim
kardashian's like going hey make sure
you get a butt lift make sure you do
your nose never yeah society
is going well look at them they're fake
and kim's like whoa hold up this is what
i like i think it's pretty you guys vibe
with and i have all the followers in the
world cool i would have done this
regardless what she did because remember
big asses when she was in high school
was not the thing when my girl who was
given this god-giving ass she didn't
it's not fake she was born with that ass
when she was coming to high school that
wasn't the hot thing
because of kim kardashian curves and
those big asses are the thing now kim
didn't ask for that society put that on
her so now the society's going oh but
you got a nose job too she's like yeah
that's what i like to do
i'm not telling people to get nose jobs
yeah right these are so it's not like
it's not on cam it's on society probably
not even a s i i in a lot of ways all of
this talk isn't isn't the hill to die on
it's like that's yeah that was my
takeaway it's like um oh i was gonna say
the difference between
actively combating
um
like the fat acceptance movement which
is a different thing going you're
forcing this thing down by saying
everything is beautiful you're like
that's yeah it's okay to be found
unhealthy but then lock down because fat
people die faster right wait hold on do
we want to promote obesity or do we want
to say hey what we're seeing is in covet
death the underlying health condition
and being out of shape is really
dangerous that's my thing and that's it
let's just be honest about everything
there are that woman on si i in my
opinion is beautiful she's got a lot of
beauty to her siamese there are a lot of
guys there
a lot of guys that would be very happy
oh i know so many guys who are watching
did you see that chicken on sports right
she's hot yes cool man if you see her
other pictures like if you saw her
walking down the street she's a she's
very pretty
um
having said all that i do think also
that
when the fat acceptance movement is i
don't actually have a problem with that
but but but please be honest with the
fact that it's not healthy that they're
they're you can get to a point where you
are very heavy and it's going to put you
at higher risk for code but you don't
hear them say that let's be
straightforward because you can be you
can be extreme one side and then the
other thing is it's a different
conversation
saying i don't believe in extreme fat
acceptance ideology is a different thing
than being like
individually this chick ain't pretty
which feels more like fat shame yeah
i don't like top piercing came off like
a little it's like yeah so they're like
related but also i guarantee the
backlash i know the backlash that he's
getting from his crowd like i think
that's where you he's gonna have to
check himself yes for him to say oh
twitter's being mean like for me like if
i was getting hate because i was spewing
hate if i was saying brian counts the
worst comic ever [ __ ] him i've only been
doing six years i'm better than him yeah
dude you deserve all the hate you're
getting yeah you you signed up for this
buddy you're the one criticizing other
comics have you ever heard him criticize
a comic no have you ever heard me talk
gossip and go bad on anybody no never
when i have every right to especially
now i could light some of these [ __ ]
terrible comics up who are judging me
easily i never would i don't play that
game but for jordan peterson who plays
that game and then goes i'm out you guys
are toxic he's like well dude you just
spit venom yeah and you knew what you
were doing and now that you're getting
out of it because even your fan base
like whoa dude that's not cool yeah
that's not cool yeah and i think it's a
positive that people came to her defense
in a way yeah you know like because i i
don't like that fat chanting [ __ ] at all
and i and i the other thing is i
guarantee that woman already got plenty
of hate i guarantee that they put her on
there and her name is yumi new she's
obviously i guarantee dealing with a
whole bunch of [ __ ] who just feel
like they gotta say some [ __ ] to her
that's not very nice but even kim
kardashian nobody gets more hate than
kim kardashian also but kim's not out
there going make sure you yeah she's bad
dude like kim kardashian isn't out there
going make sure she's there she's
gorgeous dude yeah
like and shows the other one go back for
a sec go back i'm gonna tell you right
now those two girls show up at a [ __ ]
party and
there are a lot of guys that are going
to be looking to
get involved yeah most guys yeah
now are a lot of them black
yeah i didn't say that
i didn't say that there may not be a lot
of skinny white guys we're all thinking
it no a lot of skinny white girls are
into that skinny white boys are into
that too
right
and there's a different stigma around it
in like she's beautiful amongst the
creatures but she's hot now when she
turns i think she's hot no me too she's
bad as [ __ ] but when she turns 50 it
could get dicey maybe is she polynesian
what's what's her natural no no no yumi
sounds japanese yeah that sounds yeah
she's better i bet her dad's [ __ ] dude i
call it right now before you look it up
i bet her dad's japanese born and raised
her mom is from nebraska
i would guess
that big baby now hold on i'm going to
say i'm going to say scandinavian i got
she's got she definitely has some white
in her ducks and dutch oh dutch big
people dutch the ducks are big yep
japanese and dutch all right
there you go but then people are also
mad that kim kardashian's also on the
front cover of sports illustrated like
oh we're promoting it kim got way more
hate than this big girl yeah why you're
telling me kim karda who posts a picture
in a that like thong string bikini have
you seen that
if that doesn't make your dick call
you like man
and that's fine
let me see but people like i can't like
i've lost so much respect for sports
illustrated okay
are you [ __ ] me go to that other one
chin when she's in the pool like why did
they go like an alligator with their ass
out why do they no not the old lady yes
that's sports illustrated you have
problem with anybody
the two covers the big girl on her kim
got more hate can i ask you guys have
you ever been offended by a woman's body
because because there's ten people on
the planet that look like that
and i'm married to one yeah have you
ever been offended by a woman dressing
like scantily because it seems like some
men are sort of like their knee-jerk
reaction is like oh it's slut-shaming
it's slut-shaming but it's like they
talk themselves there's certain guy
friends i have that have this instinct
where they'll complain to me about like
that's because they jim in there i'm
like dude i don't care i never have that
emotion look at her but
mark that's because those guys could
never touch that girl it's like the same
person that's driving a 1997 toyota
camry shout out to the cameras and my
mom jumping but you're driving a toyota
camry in 1997 and a ferrari pulls awake
those are [ __ ] stupid right it's like
that piece of [ __ ] man who would drive
that
oh you feel that way that's your own
that's your own insecurity that's why
you're mad at that's why you're mad at
kim kardashian's claudia you could never
touch her never yeah now there might be
a little hope because she's dating pete
davidson
right so that you're like maybe right
and you know our boy uh uh [ __ ] comic
new york guy vesti um uh paul verzie
paul verzi um he's really good friends
with pete davidson he said i go what's
he like he goes he's the nicest guy in
the world yeah i do i'm at the common
store i'm in the green room he's the
nicest guy i always defend pete yeah
pizza good dude that's another one
people guys go like i don't get it it's
like
i get it i can look and see why women
love him
and has styles
yeah he's got a lot of music he's
original he's an original and a kind
person all right let's go oh more good
take they'll be
yeah i think that i'm usually on board
jordan peterson then when that when i as
soon as i saw it my brother sent to me
screenshot goes look at your appearance
on it oh he [ __ ] up the stuff [ __ ]
up a little bit and now you got it now
you got to do damage control because
because a lot of your fans aren't going
to win the olympia dude and they you
know
they everyone struggles with that
okay that was a bit of a knee-jerk thing
yeah
and but then you're going to get out
yeah come on you got to take it on the
chin buddy if you're if you're going to
spew hate you get it back you can't go
this place is too toxic i'm out of here
no no no stan stay in the cut dude stay
in that foxhole you're the one that
asked for it man that's like throwing a
bomb at russia and then getting mad
they're bombing you back now you gotta
stay in the foxhole dude
we knew what he was trying to say
because we talked about this before on
the shows before but for whatever he's
so smart i'm surprised he put that tweet
out old man's vibes yeah it's a
conversation it's kind of like what he's
saying is that there's a lot of
scientific literature that would suggest
that beauty standards are not solely
cultural yeah they are there are certain
through lines that all societies
throughout time have held up to be
beauty when you're speaking of feminine
beauty and even male beauty yeah no so
well but that's like me being mad at
arnold schwarzenegger and sylvester
stallone because when i grow up when i
grew up that those were my nose charts
that's why i saw on tv there's no
podcast there's no social media so i was
like oh i want to be jacked like them
yeah now that i'm not jacked like them
you think i'm like those pieces of [ __ ]
how dare they give me this false hope no
dude they work their ass off to a ton of
steroids i was eight yes and i thought
by getting a flat top i'd be shredded
i'm not male beauty is interesting
because well with women they they've
done these studies with what do women
find the most attractive across the
board big eyes strong
big nose probably big no big nose is on
there yeah but it's masculine so broad
broad shoulder caveman
like a proportion of waist to shoulders
broad shoulders
height
broad shoulders big eyes strong jaw yeah
like caveman like as close as you can
get to a caveman just in their dna yeah
provider protector those are those
things that resonate with us there are
certain red things that resonate with
our psychic structures
like dna yeah and they're like
one of the things that
carl jung noticed was that when people
have dreams fears and go into states of
psychosis where they go crazy
no matter where they are on the globe
they all have very similar fears similar
nightmares yeah they're certain it's
the shadows the darkness the snakes yes
all that it all and all kind of so small
hands yeah
small i don't know what you're talking
about you're tired of seeing that
going bald
ireland offers basic income for artists
hey you're missing uh you're missing the
millie dinner
[ __ ] man you're not there i gotta be in
west palm beach
this weekend everybody yeah give it to
him friday saturday sunday west palm
beach improv i'm bringing heat so come
say hi now are you gonna make the show
on monday we've talked about this daddy
daddy is leaving at 8 00
a.m it's going to be tough but i will
buy this here at 12 30. oh wow that's
dedication brother come on oh jeff dies
on wednesday oh beautiful um
great yeah but the the melee dinner is
on thursday because i told holt stat
listen i'll be completely honest i did
not think the special hit a million
views so when mike was like what's the
goal i said
a success to me you know around a
million i don't think he's gonna hit
that and mike goes what if it does i go
tell you what since you guys shot at all
this if it's a million views i'll take
the entire staff out to scope on my
favorite restaurant yeah and mike said
promise me a shake on it okay and so we
have 12 people staff's 12 you know and
so you get the private room got the
private room i love it yep they can
order whether they want to run you some
money but it's
going to cost you some money so it's so
worth it we've worked so hard on it it's
all worth it it's been yeah it's going
to be great
celebration but you me
you and me and maybe somebody else yep
we'll go to a republic yep
yep yep
that's what we'll do i need you to get
involved i know just scope out you know
then then they've been you know scope a
blast my special out and they have tiger
thick whiskey there do they yeah dude so
it's like
those are our boys man i was saying on
on the shop show i went on a hard rant
on judging but on the shop show i was
saying how
scopa was our
cheers when i first came to l.a scopa
was like our um we ran friends when they
hung out that coffee shop but i forget
what it's called but that was like our
hangout like we'd always meet their dude
yes that was always our show so close it
was the best we were always there i
still do it that's where abby kitty
fight club came from i know it's great
um uh now
now uh the [ __ ] was i gonna say what are
you gonna say hey um you looked at the
whisper tiger thick tiger
public
my big dick uh my buddy my i'm gonna
[ __ ] put him on blast my [ __ ]
buddy brian cooley he's got um two jiu
jitsu schools in nashville right mm-hmm
and uh
uh the [ __ ] guy he's the one who
introduced me to whiskey like i remember
he was drinking blanton's
and i
gave me some plans i was like i like
whiskey so i kind of went down the
rabbit hole because of brian [ __ ] guy
and i hope he listens to this [ __ ]
guy comes to my house i have a little
you know get together on a friday to
celebrate the special and stuff we're
all drinking and i got some somebody
gave me this gift of this really nice
whiskey what was it he's a big boy he's
six six about 2 55 260 big big guy yeah
too big and uh and he starts drinking
whiskey and then four hours later
he [ __ ] looks at me he goes he's
wrecking rounds
sorry i got what he was
empty bottle totally sober
empty bottle oh he can drink he can
drink and he was completely sober i was
like how the [ __ ] did you drink a bun
and also hey
and then he just kind of threw it away
because i'll buy some new whiskey you
don't remember whiskey was it it was an
it was a nice expensive bourbon that
somebody gave me as a gift thanks bry
thanks a lot
he's down to [ __ ]
yeah whatever he's a veteran i came back
oh yeah he gave back come on now that
that bottle of tiger thick that's for
your house right you're not gonna email
it to somebody did you promise that to
somebody else this is my private
consumption and uh i need i need a
blended whiskey i need i need a japanese
bourbon i like this whiskey i'm not just
saying this rogan me and rogan were
talking about it it's a really good
whiskey it really is it's it's a it's an
excellent did he did he say that to you
on the show mm-hmm it's a good whiskey
and he got drunk on the show so drunk i
had to pull the uber over and throw up
oh okay yep i said it yeah yeah yeah
i didn't eat i didn't eat that day
i need you to eat
i know all right what else yeah
i feel fine i'm light-headed what do you
got
all right you guys were talking about us
earlier ireland where are we
yeah yeah it's the first time you've
heard of it
i like that they're supporting their
artists art is the cornerstone of a
culture and that's what that's what
korea did korea the reason korea has
k-pop korea has animation amazing music
animation is they they
they had a government program to support
their artists they said we are going to
create we're going to create a program
where we
ex we export our artistic expressions to
the wrestling as a part of the trial two
thousand artists will be randomly
selected from all the applications
shouldn't be randomly
like the best the best ones get the best
artist you know the difference but how
do you qualify yourself as an artist
let's see the want visual or i draw i
draw on my off timer
visual arts theater literature music
dance opera film circus and architecture
now this isn't that surprising come from
ireland right they you know they do
their thing now if russia did this that
would be cool if north korea did this
that would be cool yeah like russia are
not up in here this is iceland right
this is ireland oh it's ireland oh i'm
sorry ireland's super arctic iron it's
cool it's a [ __ ] whole tradition of
that that's amazing that's really cool
wow i like it i like the idea hey could
they pick a less looking irish guy for
the cover i know go ahead scroll down
it's like a good artist though but would
you like him to go oh yeah he's irish
no black irish
i saw this from sam tripoli tripoli
posted something about uh brittany
greiner you know she's still stuck in
russia do you know the details on this
was it cbd or was it
in china that's why i asked you because
i know you didn't because i want to
explain it so here's the thing brittany
grant you know who that is
she's a star in the wnba she's a giant
right she's a good player really good
player
the w babe makes
no money here they're basically open
mikers on the nba scene the wma makes no
money yeah just a market value what can
you do so a lot of these female pro
basketball players make tons of money
playing in russia overseas and that's
where they make them so they're playing
year round they play wnba then they go
to russia and they paid millions of
dollars
the issue with that is a lot of the
oligarchs own a lot of those teams
so you have
a free pass in russia she's not going
through
you know most of [ __ ] most u.s citizens
have to go through she has a special
privilege
but the thing is is when the war started
she thought oh the oligarch's going to
help me well the thing is these
oligarchs getting taken out left and
right they're on yachts in [ __ ] dubai
where they're trying to get to they're
trying to get out of russia because
they've done a lot of bad [ __ ] they want
to get out of there so she goes she's
stopped in the airport she has uh uh a
pen but it's not cbd cbd is a little
dicey of russia it had weed in it it was
a weed pin and in russia they don't [ __ ]
with that now usually if they weren't at
war
you call the oligarch he's like yeah who
is it gary gary what's up at tsa or
whoever let her through yeah problem is
is that oligarch is on a yacht evading
authority and we can't contact them so
we're going to shut you down so then
they took her as a prisoner now and
she's been in there for months horrible
so now russia is like yeah give us this
war criminal we'll give you this wnba
basketball player and this shows you how
much americans value wnba basketball
players they went
let's think on it now if that was steph
curry
we would have traded [ __ ] osama bin
laden in 30 minutes for him
that's because we care about steph curry
that's right this just shows you america
doesn't give a [ __ ] and we're leaving
her in there
it's so offensive it's very funny funny
she's a tall woman very tall
oh it did yeah should dunk her [ __ ]
right in your nose dude yeah yeah she
can duck yeah she can dunk
brittany grinder she's got a girlfriend
six nine i didn't know that she was that
tall
that's eight is that real giant yeah
that's real dude she's a super bowl what
the hell six nine yeah dude
and candace parker six four she's
gorgeous
yeah
yeah she played at baylor she was a
beast dude
yeah but she is a shoe size 17. wow 17
women's is what men's was that like a 14
no
17 in women's
wait what is
yeah it's a large shoe
wait let me see the other which one
not the other
uh what men's size is 17 women's there
you go
she wears a 15 and a half that's a large
girl
well she's got it she's long nipples i
don't want to talk about that what yeah
like you have guys a big fan big dicks
no women have blood i'm not talking long
nipples with big feet nope don't yeah
hey i just tried jin bought the hook got
her racquel penny put climbing in here
mouth bass right now he'll climb it yeah
chin bought it yeah just
i was hoping so pick up on it okay we'll
just do this one since we don't have
that much time yeah please all right
this is just a jewish jewelry store
smash and grab oh i love this and are
they korean chin they're asian are they
asian yeah because i saw them in the
news this morning and then one dude gets
such a good shot and he gets in the head
with a hammer but beats the [ __ ] out i
love it but check this out so yeah who's
in l.a
of course don't fight it's korean don't
[ __ ] with i don't know if they're asian
but let me check another asian chin okay
let's see i don't know if all of them
are family-owned though all right
look at these guys just strolling in
dude first of all
nobody stopped them on the streets
i don't ask her this girl is just like
she's so calm
now see the top look at the guy look at
that boom boom he gets hit with a hammer
still thrown yeah
gotta watch he's asian you gotta watch
him at the top look he's the computer
look
watch him he's a superhero i love him
watch it you never know dude look at him
look he comes sprinting look at this oh
hell nah
boom nice
that's fine boom she's still fighting
dude
dude who is she
i know she's a badass i mean they're all
[ __ ] badass they just go behind them
no he he was on ktla this morning
talking about it he was age okay i don't
know what kind of asian but i would say
korean yeah tough you never know tough
either way but that's cool you know you
always say like
they always say like don't do stuff like
this but if people keep doing stuff like
this there's gonna be less attacks and
here's the problem perhaps if those
robbers had a gun
i know but i'm
but i did read in uh i think it was
encino this guy uh broke into this
family's house and the husband went
excuse me
cuesh good shot and killed him good you
don't have that guy
and nothing he went to lunch that's
right yep that's what he said what
happened nothing no report you're coming
to lunch house you get shot in the
[ __ ] head dummy
[ __ ] you that's how we roll bro i'll
tell you i will shoot you right now 3
30. i don't give a [ __ ] everybody i
don't give a [ __ ] and i work out
yesterday too i don't take time off dunk
your nuts in some kool-aid dude i won't
i know you're gonna look i'll dude i'll
tell you right now i'm gonna dunk my
nuts on portland because i'm in portland
we're going to portland june 9th through
the 11th
all right june 9th and 11th i'm off
before that uh i've set right in l.a
okay yeah come on daddy daddy stop don't
stop i'm like a shark yep you know some
guys they like to stop moving i stopped
moving your boy dies here that's why i
take so many [ __ ] uppers anyways uh
la's wednesday night that thing sold out
jeff dye crystalia trevor wallace craig
the monsters but then portland oregon
portland let's do it baby june 9th
through the 11th you and i have had some
good times there yes we have june i miss
you man june 9th through the 11th is
portland helium then san francisco cobbs
is two shows friday two shows saturday
at the cobb's comedy place in san
francisco
club yep and then san diego california
that's at the new laugh factor in san
diego the heart of san diego and what's
fun about this is your boys going east
coast we just added two new east coast
dates to it our boy alistair's gonna be
with his chin my video out for we're in
baltimore i'm at baltimore i think with
goobies okay baltimore mcgoobies august
4th through the 6th just got added
houston just got added september 15th
and september 17th and then my favorite
i passed on wilbur wilbur you know i
love you but i love boston i want the
reps you're doing boston that's a great
question yes i've always wanted to do it
great fun and they always tell me do
wilbur i want to spend time in boxing
you're going to love real but i still
love you but i'm at laugh boston yes
september 29th october 1st thursday
through saturday i'm going to shave my
head like whitey bulger there you go and
we're blue eye contacts west palm beach
florida you're up friday saturday sunday
with one of my favorite places to
perform here you're missing the milly
dinner hope it's worth it it's going to
be good we keep missing stuff right now
i got the funny bone the next weekend
didn't realize have you bought my
tickets you had june 3rd that's a friday
saturday hey daddy tickets right now
tickets right now yeah inflation oh
tough a little tough omaha nebraska
funny bones june 10 and 11. i'm excited
about that and then i got ontario i
think we'll take the summer off
improv now i don't [ __ ] around dude i
don't [ __ ] around there you go there it
is you're all over dude there it is uh
new think boy merch is dropping you see
me with the the
the long tees in white black with thick
boy logo and the yellow hoodie that you
see me rocking you see you'll see the
yellow hoodie on
the flashback fight night this week with
eric griffin we watch my losses it goes
awful i get really sad so that's cool
but that merch drops thursday at 9am on
thinkboy.com you'll see me rocking on
kingston you see me on social media
rocking it so my favorite merch so
that's it if you want whiskey uh
thickboy.com you see the tiger thick
whiskey on there we got a distributor
baby online we worldwide nationwide our
distributors out of freaking dc daddy
all right go to thinkboy.com for
everything tour dates everything the new
summer tour dates are up right now
thinkboy.com portland europe
all right dude another great one another
great one my friend let's go dip your
nuts some kool-aid it's just called old
school fighter and a kid if everybody's
afraid of that and how about mark harley
as a great audience
smart kid
chin doing the goddamn thing
this is the final kid we're out
yeah